[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe visual politik zuschauer gleich zu
beginn eine kleine frage an euch wusstet
ihr überhaupt dass es ein land namens
worum die gibt bevor ihr auch dieses
video geklickt habt ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass nur wenige von euch in der
lage wären es auf einer unbeschrifteten
landkarte zu finden dabei hat es beruhen
die in sich denn es ist weltweit
spitzenreiter in einer ganz bestimmten
disziplin es ist das ärmste land der
welt ganz genau brody ist sogar für
afrikanische verhältnisse schrecklich
arm
[Musik]
mit einem pro-kopf-einkommen von nur
274 dollar pro jahr hängt warum die
seinen afrikanischen nachbarstaaten
deutlich hinterher im vergleich in
liberia ist dieses dreimal so hoch und
die aussichten für die zukunft sind noch
schlechter warum reden also heute über
beruhen die nun bald direkt daneben ein
anderes land liegt das in der
vergangenheit ebenfalls durch sehr
unrühmliche dinge wie zb einen
bestialischen bürgerkrieg inklusive
unvorstellbar brutalen völkermord
hervorstach woanders
[Musik]
wonder und beruhen die sind quasi
verband brüder wenn man so will oder
cousins ersten grades beide länder waren
einmal belgische kolonie genaugenommen
bildeten sich zusammen sogar eine
kolonie man könnte also sagen dass die
ice das gleiche land waren auch heute
teilen sie noch eine gemeinsamkeit in
beiden ländern herrschen diktatoren
allerdings gestaltet sich die situation
in ruanda durchaus ganz anders als in
seinem nachbarland natürlich ist ruanda
immer noch verhältnismäßig arm aber
schaut euch mal diese beiden fotos an
auf der linken seite sie ihr votum bora
die hauptstadt von bund und die eine
ziemlich trostlose landschaft nicht war
auf der rechten seite liegt kigali die
hauptstadt rollen darf man kann ihr die
armut natürlich auch ansehen aber zu den
kleinen hütten und häuser an gesellen
sich auch moderne wolkenkratzer hotels
und andere arten fortschrittliche
infrastruktur aber nun genug der fotos
lässt uns über zahlen reden wenn wir uns
diese beiden diagramme ansehen wird
deutlich dass die beiden ländern nicht
unterschiedlicher sein könnten
wie ihr sehen könnt waren beide länder
in den 60er jahren gleich amt aber
anschließend wächst ruanda wie verrückt
während grund elend zu versinken scheint
die frage die sich nun hier also stellt
lautet warum handelt es sich bei boni
immer noch um das ärmste land der welt
und warum wächst ausgerechnet sein
nachbarland ruanda so viel schneller was
machen sie anders diese fragen
beantworten wir in unserem heutigen
video und wie so oft fand wir hierzu mit
einem kurzen blick in die hochgradig
bewegte geschichte der beiden länder
also aufgepasst
der vergessene krieg
wie würdet ihr regieren wenn ich euch
sagen würde dass man ethnische rassen
vom schreibtisch eines regierungsbüros
aus schaffen kann also dass ein bürokrat
klassische trennungen vornimmt wo früher
eine relativ homogene gesellschaft
existierte klingt durch typisch
machiavellis tisch und verdammt stark
nach den nürnberger rassegesetzen der
nazis nicht war nun die deutschen waren
auch hier nicht die ersten die diese
grausige idee hatten denn genau das
haben die belgischen siedler in dem
gebiet getan dass sie ruanda burundi
nannten denn viele historiker behaupten
dass dieses gebiet afrikas in der
vergangenheit zu einer der ethnisch
homogenen regionen des kontinents zählt
aber wie belgischen kolonialherren
beschlossen eine künstliche trennung zu
schaffen gut tust auf der einen und
tutsi auf der anderen seite das nach dem
alten prinzip teile und herrsche
plötzlich mussten alle ureinwohner einen
ausweis bei sich tragen der zeigte zu
welcher gruppe sie gehörten die tutsi
die in der minderheit waren wurden dabei
dazu auserkoren die schicht der
privilegierten zu bilden sie bekamen
durch die belgischen kolonisten die
besten jobs zugeteilt und die hutus
welche die mehrheit bildeten bekamen die
miesesten jobs sie sollten die
unterschicht sein dass alles schuf eine
menge leid und nach und nach kannst du
immer größeren spannungen in der
gesellschaft
1962 erlangte woanders die
unabhängigkeit von belgien und wandelte
sich in folge zu den beiden staaten die
wir heute kennen runde auf der einen
seite und warum die auf der anderen
grundsätzlich wird sich immerhin dieser
historische schritt ja ganz gut an nicht
wahr zwei länder die ihre freiheit
erlangen und endlich vom joch der
kolonialmacht befreit ihr eigenes glück
suchen können nun stand einem aufschwung
nichts mehr im weg oder nun die bittere
wahrheit ist alles kam völlig anders den
tus dem volk das in der minderheit war
wurde die burundische regierung
überlassen was wiederum zu protesten der
bub führte daraufhin kam es auf befehl
ebendieser die regierung zur ermordung
von der verein 100 bis 200 tausend in
ruanda kam es etwas anders wobei mit
ähnlich schrecklichen ergebnis in diesem
fall haben die hutu 0 73 einen
putschversuch durchgeführt und
infolgedessen tausende von tussi
massakriert oder aus dem land vertrieben
der eigentliche große völkermord
ereignisse sich jedoch erst 1990 er
jahren und die entscheidende frage dabei
ist vor allem was denn genau das
ereignis war dass dieses massaker
ausgelöst hat aufgepasst die präsidenten
von ruanda und burundi stärkung nach
einem anschlag auf das flugzeug in dem
sie unterwegs waren haben wir sechster
april 1994 waren die beiden präsidenten
von ruanda und burundi gemeinsam in
einem flugzeug unterwegs als die
maschine gerade dabei war eine
romantischen hauptstadt kigali aktuellen
landung anzusetzende schoss eine rakete
das flugzeug die beiden präsidenten
starben und die beiden länder geräten
jeweils in einen schrecklichen
bürgerkrieg in ruanda begann das von ihm
geführte regierungsrat nachrichten wie
diese zu senden
[Musik]
in nur 100 tagen willen ist den guten 11
prozent der bevölkerung woanders
abzuschlachten ja ihr habt richtig
gehört der ruandischen völkermord ist
als eine der grausamsten episoden der
menschheitsgeschichte in die annalen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist eingegangen
wir reden hier nicht nur von einer armee
die menschen tötete es waren auch die
zivilisten selbst die mit macheten
bewaffnet auf die straße gingen um ihren
nachbarn auf die grausamste art und
weise nieder zu metzeln all das
ereignete sich in ruanda wie gesagt
innerhalb eines relativ kurzen zeitraums
von 100 tagen ich sage relativ kurz denn
im nachbarland burundi lief ist etwas
anders ab dort herrschte jahrzehntelang
ein nie enden wollender bürgerkrieg in
den nutzern 70er jahren hatten die tussi
hunderttausende hutu ermordet und in den
90er jahren kehrte man den spieß um mit
anderen worten beide länder erlebt in
einem ähnlich blutigen krassen krieg der
sich in vielen punkten gleich aber
aufgepasst denn jetzt kommt der große
und entscheidende unterschied in ruanda
organisierten sich ihnen flüchtlinge die
es geschafft hatten den gemessen zu
entkommen in flüchtlingslagern
und hier kommt der mann ins spiel den
ihr gerade auf dem bildschirm sieht paul
kagame kagame schaffte es den meisten
morden ein ende zu bereiten und wurde im
jahr 2000 präsident von ruanda wer ist
heute ist er amtierender präsident
woanders ist nach wie vor weit davon
entfernt eine demokratie zu sein aber
darüber sprechen wir später lasst uns
zuerst zur situation in wohlen die
zurückkehren dort gestaltet sich alles
ganz anders ist es jahr 2003 herrschte
noch bürgerkrieg und inmitten dieses
geschehens erschien dort ebenfalls eine
neue person auf der piste die peters
hirt für die geschichte des landes
werden sollte der mann auf diesem bild
pierre nkurunziza von 2005 bis 2020
hatte er das amt des präsidenten von pur
und die innen und die frage ist nun wie
haben sich die beiden länder seitdem
eigentlich entwickelt nun genau das
scheint erstmal etwas genauer an also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
ein land ohne motorräder
um es vorweg gleich klarzustellen die
geografische lage büro dies ist nicht
gerade günstig zunächst einmal verfügt
das land über keine natürlichen
ressourcen außerdem liegt es nicht am
meer es gibt also keine hätten um etwas
exportieren zu können im jahr 2000 gab
ist jedoch gute nachrichten für das land
das im jahr 2000 unterzeichnete abkommen
bot neue demokratische versprechen
inklusive institutionelle regelungen und
einer größeren rechenschaftspflicht der
politischen eliten der friedensprozess
in burundi wurde daher von ausländischen
beobachtern gefeiert dieses abkommen
ebnete den weg für wahlen an denen
mehrere parteien teilnehmen dürften
anders als in ruanda schien büro die
demokratie mit offenen armen zu
empfangen
im jahr 2005 trat dann unser protagonist
care und concealer in den vordergrund
dieser mann gehörte der ethnischen
gruppe der hutu an wollte aber die
konflikte um russische energie täten
endlich zur ruhe legen mit der folgende
botschaft kam er an die macht das in den
letzten zwölf jahren von kosten booms
ist reichlich gut reichlich genug aber
wenn er schon oft auch visuell heute
gesehen haben ist die eine sache was
politiker sagen und eine ganz andere was
sie dann tatsächlich tun die
versprechungen wurden nicht erfüllt seit
2005 ist büro die immer noch weit sehr
weit ja lichtjahre davon entfernt einen
demokratie zu sein damit ihr euch das
noch besser vorstellen könnt es ist
mitglied in einem club der länder in
denen internationale beobachter mit
einem sogenannten meinen reisen müssen
damit ist eine person aus der regierung
gemeint die dafür zuständig ist so etwas
wie der schatten eines internationalen
gastes zu sein kein beobachter kann sich
also frei im land bewegen und sehen was
die regierung nicht nach außen zeigen
will bohren die gibt sich also nicht
einmal mehr die mühe auch nur die
entferntesten anzeichen einer demokratie
zu zeigen seht euch mal diese nachricht
aus dem jahr 2015 an
bundespräsident und kochen sie sage wenn
umstrittene dritte amtszeit und wie
schafft er das nun der präsident
kündigte an dass er trotz der
verfassungsmäßigen begrenzung seiner
amtszeit einfach an der macht bleiben
würde er hatte sich selbst zum channel
supreme guide ausgerufen das ist richtig
ich wiederhole der ewige oberste führer
wie ihr euch vorstellen können ließen
die proteste nach dieser selbst
ernennung nicht lange auf sich warten
und wie ihr euch ebenfalls vorstellen
könnte hat der sogenannte ewige oberste
führe sie mit aller macht unterdrückt
mehr als 400.000 menschen mussten das
land verlassen
dazu kommen noch tausende von
hingerichteten und jenen die einfach so
verschwunden sind sogar das un
menschenrechtsrat wurde geschlossen und
burundi war auf das erste land auf der
welt überhaupt das den internationalen
strafgerichtshof erst beigetreten war
und dass seine mitgliedschaft dann
wieder gekündigt habt warum nun
natürlich weil mutmaßliche verbrechen
untersucht werden sollten die zwischen
2015 und 17 begangen wurden doch von
allen repressiven maßnahmen die in
diesem land eingeführt worden ist eine
wohl die außergewöhnlichste das verbot
von motorrädern ja ihr habt richtig
gesagt motorradfahren ist eine der
schwersten straftaten die man in burundi
begehen kann und warum fragt euch jetzt
vielleicht weil es dort heißt dass
menschen auf motorrädern sich gegen die
regierung verschworen könnten klar
leuchtet ein aber das i-tüpfelchen der
erlasse des ewigen obersten führers war
diese nachricht
staatsdiener inhaftiert nachdem grundes
führer beim fußballspiel gefoult wurde
das stimmt und korn sie sah spielte in
einer mannschaft fußball lehrern trainer
auch nur zufällig war und auch ihr
besitzer und er hat beschlossen zwei
menschen nach einem fußballspiel ins
gefängnis zu werfen weil sie ihn gefoult
hatte ich meine noch nicht mal putin
würde in einem solchen fall seine ice
hockey staffage ins gefängnis werfen
oder etwa doch schreibt uns doch in die
kommentare wie ihr das seht aber zurück
nach bohrungen die zur überraschung
vieler kündigte uns dieser damals an
dass er 2009 10 nicht mehr zur
wiederwahl antreten würde der von ihm
auserwählte nachfolger evaristo und
daisy werde inzwischen auch präsident
des landes geworden ist soll er an
seiner stelle kandidieren ziemlich
unerwartet für stadt und co musiker
nämlich kurze zeit darauf an einem
herzinfarkt und ist wurden neuwahlen
abgehalten es scheint aber dass sich die
dinge seitdem nach wie vor nicht
geändert haben die hält wahlen ab die
von gewalt und den corona virus geprägt
sind mit anderen worten wir reden nicht
nur über eine rigorose diktatur
gesprächen von einer völlig
willkürlichen extrem gewalttätigen
diktatur ihr fragt euch inzwischen
vielleicht auch welche art von
wirtschaftlich überhaupt in einem
solchen land entwickeln konnte nun
schaut euch dazu einfach mal diese
grafik an
sie zeigt burundis exporte als prozent
seines bip es wie ihr seht sind sie
nicht nur viel niedriger als der
durchschnitt ganz afrika südlich der
sahara der trend ist zudem rückläufig
und was bräuchte ein land ohne
ressourcen bildung oder infrastruktur am
meisten inland die bohrung die ganz
genau ausländische investitionen das
heißt menschen die bereit sind
irgendwelche fabriken zu bauen und know
how ins land zu bringen das nicht
unbeachtliche problem dabei wer würde in
einem land wo und wie überhaupt
investieren wollen denn für nicht einmal
gibt es drei wesentliche hindernisse
kreis bürokratie keine rechtssicherheit
und korruption zum beispiel gibt es
überall checkpoints und an allen wird
die hand aufgehalten das bedeutet dass
der transport von waren zum nächsten
hafen ein vermögen kosten kann wenn man
auf dem festplatz sitzen
ihr flug kommt das worum die das am
dichtesten besiedelte land afrikas ist
und das bevölkerungswachstum enorme
ausmaße angenommen hat was zusammen mit
dem schwachen wirtschaftswachstum zu
einem kontinuierlichen anstieg der
armutsquote führt das durchschnittliche
tages einkommen beläuft sich also auf
erschreckende ein dollar 90 und das pro
kopf bip des landes gilt als das
niedrigste der welt
wo ich einen eindruck von dem konsequenz
dieser katastrophalen entwicklungen
vermitteln zu können schätzungen zufolge
sind beispielsweise nur zwölf prozent
der straßen asphaltiert das heißt die
meisten menschen müssen im staub oder im
schlamm waten mobilität ist ein
fremdwort aber wartet denn der westen
versucht verschiedene hilfen
bereitzustellen um das land von der
armut zu befreien und mit maßnahmen wie
dieser hier wo und die begrüßt die
entscheidung der eu die sanktionen gegen
das land aufzuheben nach sechs jahren
haben die europäische union und die usa
ein auge zugedrückt und die
wirtschaftssanktionen für wohnen die
aufgehoben die frage ist nur ob sich
dadurch überhaupt etwas ändern wird es
wird für burundi nämlich extrem
schwierig sei niemals etwas in die usa
oder in die eu zu exportieren da sie ja
eigentlich gar nichts zu exportieren
haben und ich kann mir schon vorstellen
was sich viele von euch jetzt denken
worum die ist dem tode geweiht es ist
unmöglich dass dieses land das geprägt
ist von seiner grausamen vergangenheit
der armut jemals entkommen kann oder nun
passt gut auf wenn jetzt zeigen wir euch
die andere seite der medaille
und dazu reisen wir nach ruanda
[Musik]
das afrikanisch festigen abholen
wie weit die einst vereinten
nachbarländer mittlerweile in ihrer
entwicklung auseinandergedriftet sind
just read ausgerechnet am besten unser
kurioses motorrad beispiel während
burundi seinem volk ein schweres
motorrad verbot auferlegt hat ist ruanda
das erste land in der region dass ein
eigenes motorrad modell entwickelt hat
klar erwartet jetzt ein hochmodernes
rennmotorrad aber zumindest haben sie
einen ausreichenden entwicklungsstand
erreicht und motorräder zu bauen und
mobilität zu sichern über das phänomen
der motorräder aus ruanda haben wir
übrigens eines unserer ersten videos auf
diesem kanal gedreht und ich werde es
euch natürlich verlinken damit ihr es
uns später anschauen könnt aber es geht
nicht nur um motorräder denke nur einmal
an die gesamte wertschöpfungskette die
nötig ist um etwas so komplex ist wie
ein motorrad herzustellen reden hier von
vielen zulieferern werkstätten und
fachkräften ruanda verfügt über all das
mit anderen worten ohne übergroße
natürliche ressourcen zur verfügung
haben sie es geschafft industrie
produkte zu entwickeln was war in ruanda
aber so anders als in burundi nun dazu
müssen wir einen blick auf die jüngere
geschichte des landes werfen
wie ich schon erwähnt habe hat es
geschafft die traumata des völkermords
viel besser zu überstehen als ein
nachbarland um den namen der
schlüsselpersonen dieser bewältigung
leistung habe ich auch schon verraten
paul kagame um eines klarzustellen
natürlich strikt paul kagame nicht
danach ein demokratischer präsident zu
sein er ist seit 22 jahren an der macht
und es sieht nicht so aus als würde er
sie so bald aus den händen geben wollen
aber seine regierung zeichnet sich durch
eine besonderheit aus die orientierung
an singapur ja das ist so verblüffend
wie es klingt denn wenn es um demokratie
geht versagt der präsident wohl
vollkommen aber in anderer hinsicht
merken wir dass er weiß was er tut und
seiner lösung zukünftige völkermord zu
verhindern begründet sich in einer
maßnahme der abschaffung der
meinungsfreiheit damit ist keinen
rassismus mehr gibt versteht uns nicht
falsch wie hier bei visual politik sie
die ersten die davor waren wenn die
angeblich gut gemeinte einschränkung von
meinungsfreiheit leicht missbraucht
werden kann entsprechende videos hierzu
werde ich euch in der beschreibung
verlinken aber alles ist eine frage der
kontextuellen proportionalität des
gesunden menschenverstandes und der
rationalen gewichte und abwägung von
risiken und nebenwirkungen des einen und
des anderen im falle rohren dass und
warum dies fällt das urteil jedoch
eindeutig aus man kann zum beispiel
anhand der einstigen hetze im russischen
radio gut nachvollziehen was hassrede in
diesem land bedeutet und zurecht
katastrophalen folgen sie führen kann
und kagame scheint seinen karl popper
wohl gelesen zu haben da schon 1945 das
sogenannte toleranz paradoxon
formulierte uneingeschränkte toleranz
führt mit notwendigkeit zum verschwinden
der toleranz denn wenn wir die
uneingeschränkte toleranz sogar auf die
intoleranten selbst ausdehnen wenn wir
nicht bereit sind eine tolerante
gesellschaftsordnung gegen die angriffe
der intoleranz zu verteidigen dann
werden die toleranten vernichtet werden
und die toleranz mit ihnen als toleranz
gilt hierbei die verweigerung eines
rationalen diskurs und der aufruf zur
anwendung von gewalt gegen
andersdenkende und anhänger ideologien
popper unterscheidet dabei jedoch ob
sich die intoleranz gegen die sitten und
gebräuche eines menschen richtet weil
diese fremd sind oder weil diese selbst
intolerant und gefährlich sind leider
ist eine scharfe abgrenzung zwischen
diesen beiden arten der intoleranz nicht
in allen fällen möglich daher sollte
auch die anwendung von intoleranz im
namen der toleranz entsprechend
vorsichtig und nur als ultima ratio
stattfinden zu hoch ist bei häufiger
anwendung sowohl das abnutzungs als auch
das missbrauchsrisiko in ruanda ist es
genau wie in singapur strengstens
verboten auch nur die kleinste
rassistische äußerung zu wahren nicht
einmal anspielungen auf hutus und tutsis
deren toleriert natürlich geht die
regierung kam es dabei so repressiv vor
wie jede andere diktatur allerdings geht
es dabei viel weniger willkürlich vor
der grad ein missbrauch scheint gering
zu sein in einer studie von transparency
international die game city den
korruptionswahrnehmungsindex erfasst
broschiert ruanda im jahr 2020 oder 180
ländern der welt auf platz 49 und bildet
das am wenigsten korrupte land der
ostafrikanischen regionen wären die
platz 165 belegt ein weiterer indikator
für das versagen burundis und wenn wir
uns nun die frage stellen ob es
politische unterdrückung und ruanda
lautet die antwort natürlich gibt es sie
aber sie unterscheidet sich nicht
maßgeblich von jeder wie wir sie auch im
übrigen afrikanischen kontinent
vorfinden hier hat es die regierung aber
wenigstens geschafft sicherheit zu
gewährleisten heute gilt sie als eine
der sichersten städte in afrika südlich
der sahara es ist schwierig zuverlässige
statistiken zu finden aber es gibt etwas
was uns immerhin einen gewissen hinweis
darauf gibt wie die dinge wirklich
laufend den tourismus erst mal einen
blick auf diese grafik
es gibt zb bereits internationale
hotelketten die in cali große anlagen
eröffnet haben diese reichen von
marriott bis radisson aber wir sprechen
nicht nur vom tourismus auch handel und
finanzdienstleistungen haben sich hier
entwickelt und ist haltet euch fest laut
dem doing business ranking ist woanders
das erste land in ganz afrika um
geschäfte zu machen und liegt außerhalb
afrikas sogar noch vor ländern wie
spanien und japan
die gründung eines unternehmens dauert
weniger als 24 stunden und es liegt
weltweit als zweiter stelle der länder
mit den besten schuss bei der
registrierung von grundeigentum und an
dritter stelle was den zugang zu
krediten angeht auf diese weise konnten
im land viele fabriken großer
unternehmen entstehen zum beispiel
riesige brauereien
technologieunternehmen und viele mehr
allerdings besteht der verdacht dass die
von ruanda vorgelegten statistiken nicht
ganz korrekt sind tatsächlich sind die
ausländischen investitionen den letzten
zwei jahren stark zurückgegangen aber
eines ist trotzdem sicher egal ist heute
eine ganz andere stadt als ihnen die
lindower neunziger jahren mit einer
horror meldung nach der anderen in den
schlagzeilen stand und die
makroökonomischen zahlen zeigen einen
großen unterschied werfen sie doch
einmal einen blick auf diese graben
der see ist brawn gp viermal kleiner als
das woanders der praktisch der gleichen
bevölkerungsdichte und dergleichen
traurigen vergangenheit
beide haben zwei unterschiedliche wege
eingeschlagen und der unterschied könnte
nicht deutlicher sein mit anderen worten
wir können aus diesem vergleich eine
ganz klare schlussfolgerung ziehen
politik ist wichtig unabhängig von der
geschichte um die natürlichen ressourcen
sind es die politischen institutionen
die den unterschied zwischen diesen
beiden ländern ausmachen
aber jetzt seid ihr gefragt haltet ihr
es ermöglicht die entwicklung eines
landes wie ruanda auch mit demokratie in
einklang zu bringen welche risiken für
die langfristige stabilität wirkt eine
diktatur nach art eines kagame könnte
das land nach seinem tod wieder im chaos
versinken oder dort kagame im alter
vielleicht verrückt werden wie so manch
anderer kollege und an land wieder in
den abgrund reißen welche lehren kann
bohrungen die von seinem erfolgreichen
nachbarland rohren da lernen und was
haltet ihr von der gewaltsamen
einschränkung der meinungsfreiheit um
eine gesellschaft zu befrieden wird dies
auf dauer funktionieren kann fast durch
seine tabuisierung gehalt werden oder
wird er dadurch nur verdeckt und dann
irgendwann noch stärker wieder hervor zu
brechen der immer sind wir auf eure
diskussion schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch die cdu gefallen hat und
vielleicht auch etwas gelernt habe als
ja gibt uns mit einleitenden worten
vergesst nicht dass awo mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mehr zu verfassen
natürlich wollen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit uns
ähnliches projekt weiterzuführen in
peter link dazu findet ihr in der
beschreibung und im video was gut und
bis bald
[Musik]